Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is a cone-based ray tracing algorithm
for rendering photorealistic images of hair
and furry objects, where the number of hair
strands is typically over a hundred thousand.
Okay, wait.
What do these term mean exactly?
Ray tracing means a bona fide light simulation
program where we follow the path of many millions
of light rays between the light sources and
our camera.
This usually means that light reflections
and refractions, lens blur and defocus are
taken into consideration.
This feature is often referred to as depth
of field, or DoF in short as you can see in
the video.
A fully ray traced system like this for hair
and fur leads to absolutely beautiful images
that you also see throughout this footage.
So what about the cone-based part?
Earlier, we had an episode about Voxel Cone
Tracing, which is an absolutely amazing technique
to perform ray tracing in real time.
It works by replacing these infinitely thin
light rays with thicker, cone-shaped rays
which reduces the execution time of the algorithm
significantly, at the cost of mostly a minor,
sometimes even imperceptible degradation in
image quality.
Since the hair strands that we're trying to
hit with the rays are extremely thin, and
cone tracing makes the rays thicker, extending
this concept to rendering fur without nontrivial
extensions is going to be a fruitless endeavor.
The paper contains techniques to overcome
this issue, and an efficient data structure
is proposed to store and find the individual
hair strands, and a way to intersect these
cones with the fibers.
The algorithm is also able to adapt the cone
sizes to the scene we have at hand.
The previous techniques typically took at
least 20 to 30 minutes to render one image,
and with this efficient solution, we'll be
greeted by a photorealistic image at least
four to six times quicker, in less than 5
minutes, while some examples were completed
in less than a minute.
I cannot get tired of seeing these tiny photorealistic
furry animals in Pixar movies and I am super
happy to see there's likely going to be much,
much more of these.
By the way, if you're subscribed to the channel,
please click the little bell next to the subscription
icon to make sure that you never miss an episode.
Also, you can also follow us on twitter for
updates.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!